what's your position and what's been
going on right now with russia and
ukraine
i think what it should start off here
right by saying it's probably the
biggest disinformation campaign that
we've ever seen like if you beyond covet
well there it is i mean is kobe the
start is that where we're at now i mean
because for you know i can get all
technical about our government and the
problems that boris johnson had for
example and how this doesn't leave it a
lot of those let's be honest i mean and
i mean he did quite well out okay to be
fair with what he did we're one of the
countries with the i think the
the more minimum locks down constraints
i think we're talking to a canadian here
who we're looking at the whole of what
was probably one of the most liberal
sort of western democracies become the
most tyrannical i think alongside maybe
new zealand and australia and things
like this so that's an interesting one
but um when you start trying to find out
what the facts are and you're going
through social media channels or even
mainstream news channels i don't know
how you can ever choose unless you go
through something like bellingcat which
tries to identify locations and things
like that how do you even know where the
disinformation is coming from or what
kind of angle some of these guys are
coming from it's
i can't even work it out myself you know
i struggle with it
what what do you see right now as far as
the sources of the disinformation
because i mean you open with that as
like the big point so what are you
seeing you know based on your experience
well i think you could you could take
this information from like literally
every side it's and it's not even over
this information it's not even like the
maskarovka we see or or whatever it
might be the hybrid warfare that russia
has been
implementing for so many so many years
that we're so familiar with it's even
when you get maybe say the prime um the
president sorry of ukraine maybe
standing up and saying
whatever he's saying and putting an
emphasis on it and of course that
appears on the front page of a newspaper
and there's you know there's little kids
there there's women as children
everything else it's
you just got to say where's the
imbalance you know where is the balance
is it an imbalance where is it are we
seeing anything that is fair or
justified and i just want to say by the
way that there's no way i'm saying this
invasion was in any way um is anyway
acceptable to anyone and it's most
ridiculous thing ever but there's
probably reasons why it happened if we
can get into that later so i try and
i'm really i'm really struggling between
trying to find out what what is right by
using mainstream news sources and that
going back into something like
uh you know twitter or anything like
that or any online source really and
trying to work out where they've got
better angles on it um you know how you
kind of know the journalists that you
trust and then those journalists become
we saw it at kobe didn't we those
journalists become kind of all in on one
side but they're not saying they're all
in they're trying to make out the
balance but they're kind of going all in
and all in again
and you think
well now who do i now kind of turn to
and i must admit to be fair i'm a little
bit lost about the whole thing and i've
been covering it like like yeah you know
so
so i look at it like you have to look at
motivations because there's the time of
unbiased sources is gone
and so i have to look at it from a
standpoint of all right what is the
motivation
of each different party and then when a
news source comes out
where are they getting that information
from and how are they cherry-picking
that information to fit that narrative
and then from there it's a starting
point at least of figuring out what's
kind of true what's not and then trying
to find raw sources as well so like now
for me i have a benefit of knowing
different people in different areas of
government i'm not
i'm kind of out of it now right i'm just
an infantry guy in the national guard
now but i've been on special operations
tears and i've been on several
deployments and i've i know people
in government positions right now i know
people in the pentagon now i can't
disclose a lot of that stuff and
anything they may disclose to me they're
they're limited in what they can even
say on certain things but i'll get
different information from those sources
video clips that people put on different
like
was it something 360 like there's
different sites that where they'll allow
you to put uncensored
clips of what's going on the battlefield
different things like that and so you
just kind of have to vet through it a
bit from that but knowing though like if
i'm watching something that's pro-nato
pro ukraine
it's going to be spun to fit a narrative
now that doesn't mean it's not true but
maybe it's
uh elevated or maybe it's
um you know
whatever you know exaggerated write the
information
great example you know what was that's
that island where there was 13 guys that
said okay fu
and then they were killed and they
weren't you know and all this but they
weren't killed right exactly they're
captured you know and so that's a huge
like oh this hero story now why would
they do that well because they need to
they're one of the biggest assets that
they need in ukraine is people to fight
right i mean so they need a lot of
things they need ammo they need money
they need weaponry but they need people
to stick around and want to stick it out
and fight and so they have to ignite
these people to do that rather than get
complacent and give up against the much
larger military force and that's how
they're gonna do it you know they're
gonna have those hero stories to
you know
get them
motivated to to get out there and keep
fighting and that's why you know it's a
big reason for that and then russia has
their own
campaign that they're running so that
they can so putin can still have the
support
from his people at least enough to not
get
you know murdered or somehow or you know
have revolts in the streets in russia
they have to he has to exhibit control
over people and he does it through his
own disinformation thing and by force
too it's kind of both hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you